咁我今日嘅聚会呢有个名嘅,个名叫你的聚社了,可能你觉得你咁唐突嘅呢,第一次见面,为何会讲话你的聚社面呢,咁旁边有幅画嘅,旁边有幅相,咁其实嗰幅相呢,系从呢本书嗰度嚟嘅,咁我唔知你见唔见到我手上,依家揸住呢本书啦,咁呢本书咁,我諗就唔系好多人睇一明,因为呢佢用尼泊尔文写成嘅,咁我就喺呢个加德满都买嘅,咁就,
这里是主耶稣在地上的一件事
稍后我们会有机会讲一下
刚才当你听完Killy
听完细辉说
不知道你羡慕他们人生的改变
我就想起圣经这一句话
它说什么呢
唯有那个以力量促我们腰
使我们行为完全的
它是神
今日我们认识这位神,他不是一道道理,他是活生生的一位
有人说近朱者赤,近物者黑
你回到信神的人,他人生都有改变,有经历
都会变好,从这里你可以看见,不单是神是真,并且他是很好的
他是用力量冲到我们的腰,使我们行为完全的那一位
我都盼望你今日因着认识这位神
你人生都有这样的改变
在我的枱头有一个摆设
经常提醒我神是很真实的
你见不见到我手上握着这件事
可能就黑一点
其实这个是一个持浮的地球仪
咁我有时都买嘢送畀自己
咁就呢个地球2提醒我啲咩嘢呢
咁喺以前呢好多人呢以为地球系平嘅
所以到今日呢都有一个学会叫做国际地平学会
就话地球系平嘅咁样
咁所以以前嗰啲人讲呢
行船跑马三分掩
点解呀
点解行船咁危险呀
因为他觉得地球是平的
如果走得远
他就会跌下去
好像一个瀑布中了下去
所以以前那些人航海
就会贴着在岸边走的
走一阵又远岸
下一阵又远岸
不敢远洋航行的
因为他怕跌下去瀑布
你发觉
人什么时候才知道
原来地球是圆的呢
其实去到这个
你见到呢度有两幅相啦
咁就去到呢个希腊时代呢
去到呢个公元前二三百年呢
咁有啲人都想㗎喇都諗㗎喇
就系咩
啊
睇见月食慨时候呢
月球有个阴影喎
即系太
地球遮住咗太阳嘛
有个阴影投射有啲弧度喎
啊
所以都猜想地球系有弧度㗎
比如有亦都有人留意到呢
就系
喺同一日里面呢
就喺唔同慨地方呢
发觉太阳照射的影是有不同的
在埃及的地方,影是垂直的
但是过了几百里之后
影就有一个角度
猜想到地球是有弧度的
但是到什么时候才证明到地球是圆的呢?
其实是去到中世纪,去到16世纪
所以为什么哥伦布、默哲伦那些这么出名呢?
因为他们的发现是冒着生命危险的
因为如果远洋行行,地球如果真的好像方的话,他们就一去回不了头了。
但是原来在圣经里面,有句这样的说话,在圣经《以色列书》里面,
《以色列书》是什么时候写的呢?就是在公元前的七八年,相当于中国的东周的时候,比春秋还要早。
圣经里面有一个这样的说话,神坐在地球大圈之上
原来圣经早就告诉我们,在2700年前已经告诉我们
地球是大圈来的
原文的字有个意思就是立体的,三维的
所以有些英文就译作The sphere of the earth
即是说地球的球体上面
又例如,以前的人就觉得地球一定是有东西吊住,有东西托住的,因为如果没有东西吊住,没有东西托住,就不断地跌,但是大家有没有一种跌的感觉?没有,一定是有东西吊住,有东西托住,所以你发觉在世界各地的神话里面,
都有这样的传说,比如有些被龟托着的地球,有些是大笨象,有些是大力士,可能不知道会不会是托得久,会动一动,接着就会地震,在神话里面,在人的想象里面就这样,
但圣经告诉我们不是这样, 圣经约伯记比起刚才说的二书还要早, 可能是3500至4000年前, 公元前的1500至2000年前,
圣经里面有这样一句话, 神将北极铺在空中, 将大地圆在虚空, 中文中不到, 英文下面怎么说呢?
下面怎么说呢?
它说神,它说 God, hand the earth on nothing
即是说神用帽子吊着地球
是不是很厉害?
那我问你,什么时候知道地球真的帽子吊着帽子托着?
其实是直到确实的证据是什么时候呢?
直到火箭升空
当太空人回望地球的时候发觉
咦,真的看不到有大笨象
真的看不到有大力士的肩膀
另外再加上还有就是什么?就是那些北极的探险,南极的探险,连最后的地方都去到了,就发觉没有绳,没有东西吊着,没有东西托着,
但是其实早在三千多四千年前,圣经已经告诉我们,神,God hand the earth on nothing,
又例如这一句说话,他说你自从生出曾命定神光,洗清神的日光,知道本位。
因着这个神光,地面改变如泥上印印。
什么意思呢?
意思就是形容日出早上的时候,地面慢慢越来越光,光的情况就像泥上印印一样。
你讲什么呀?
你知道以前的人印印是怎么印的
他就将一些图案、文字挑在一些石桶上面
然后就在泥上面,预备一个平面的泥
然后就在泥上面印
经过印之后,是不是有些图案、有些文字出来
还有这个石印又可以再印第二次,印第三次,所以当时的人他们就是这样印东西的,
那么他说为什么日出好像泥上印印那样呢?其实仿佛就是什么呢?
你发觉是不是越来越光越来越光,黑暗慢慢退去,
接着大地的那种改变就好像刚才说的印印那样,
仿佛就让我们知道原来地球好像印印那样是会转动的,是会自转的,
不单止会自转,它还会倾斜,倾斜23.5度
有什么影响呢?有,因为倾斜23.5度,所以就有春夏秋冬
所以过两天,北半球就是冬至,南半球可能就是日头最长的那一天
你发觉有春夏秋冬是不是有很多资彩?
亦都有实际功用,因为当它斜的时候,你发觉很多地方会比较温暖,更加适合人住,所以适合人住的地方就多了很多。
如果垂直转,没有斜的话,斜度就很热,而南极北极就很冷。
为什么圣经里面这么特别呢?
圣经讲了那么多关于地球、关于科学的东西
为什么这么准确呢?
甚至超过很多人的发现
要事后隔了很多年才找到证据证明所说的
原来圣经是神的话
就像这里圣经说的
圣经都是神所默示的
圣经是神的话
这个天地是神造的,当然知道这个天地的过终的细节,
所以神也透过圣经使我们认识这些,
所以透过刚才所说的,你知道圣经上的那位是真神,
而透过圣经我们也知道真神的真实,
咁唔单止圣经嘅
咁你发觉呢当你有时间去,点解啲人喜欢去旅行呀,去郊外呀
因为靓喇
当你欣赏下嗰个创造界的时候呢,你发觉又
又伟大啦
又奇妙啦
又精细啦
又靓啦
圣经里面有句这样的说话,佢话什么呢,佢话自从造天地以来
神的永能
佢永远的能力啦
和神性即是他是怎样的呢
是明明可知的
虽然眼见不到
但直接所做之物
就可以晓得
叫人无可推诿
原来透过创造界你多些去到户外看下
你都会认识神的,为什么
因为看见世界是不是很奇妙
就等于你现在见到我手上拿的手标
当你见到手标的时候你发觉是不是很漂亮
一定是有人设计,有人做的
而这个世界那种美丽,那种复杂
比这个手标复杂得多
所以当我看见这个世界的时候
我就知道真的有位设计者,有位创造者
而神他真的创造万物的
所以曾经有一个调查
就是近这几个世纪的一些杰出的科学家
这个调查发现什么呢?
因为在这些调查的科学家里面有超过九成都相信有神的
所以我和你讲信神不是不科学家
有超过九成的科学家是信有神的
为什么?因为当他越研究,当他越了解这个世界的时候
他发觉一定有一位设计者,一定有一位创造者
所以其实今天信神是很理智的
这个研究其实都曾经登过在报纸上的
不知道你有没有留意这些新闻
说到这里的时候
你们会发觉今天我们所说的这位神
圣经上面记载这位神
他是创造天地万物的
他不是人手做的
所以曾经有人说真神就是做人的
做天地万物的
假神是人造的
而誠英說到假神是有眼睛
但看不到的
有耳聽不到
有口也說不到
也不能夠在市場買賣
也不會大減價
另外剛才你聽見Kiri的見證
聽見細菲的見證
你看見神是良善是美好的
有些人是否黑社会,又拜偶像,又拜假神
黑社会又拜,祝他们嫖赌、喝醉,一切都顺利
同时,很有趣的,警察局也是拜同一个
所以当你的打劫行动失败的时候
你应该想想会不会是你所拜的通水,做了二五仔
所以从这里可以看到,这位神是创造天对万物的,他是良善的。
圣经让我们知道,神就是爱。
原来神很想人得着祂的一切好,一切丰富。
所以祂都差祂的独生儿子,神都差祂的独生儿子来,
要使人认识他,使人得到帮助。